lá muito bom aqui no ted xt dex enfim um
lugar pra gente colocar idéias né e
botar pra frente
no mundo assim onde a gente anda muito
caras na internet nem todo mundo
talvés tem sido super opiniático mas
normalmente é falando de coisas muito
pessoais e e pouco é reflexivas né acho
que aqui é um bom momento a gente
refletir
eu vou fazer uma breve apresentação é
porque está aqui eu chamo do canindé que
eu sou músico escritor é lancei o meu
primeiro disco com 17 anos solo né
depois joguei uma carreira com a cidadão
quem uma banda com a folga veio sete cds
e um dvd
depois fiz uma um projeto com humberto
gessinger chamou pouca vogal onde a
gente gravou um cd e um dvd também fez
turnê pelo brasil e agora estou no
projeto chama voz 1 e batucada grave é
escrevi três livros também meu primeiro
livro foi o a favor a casa da esquina
que foi o terceiro mais vendido da feira
de porto alegre começou a ser indicado
para as praças escolas através do
instituto estadual do livro e e assim eu
comecei a visitar as escolas e bater
papo com a galera né
justamente que é um pouco mote desse
encontro de hoje depois lancei a favor
do vento e agora estou lançando o menino
que pintava sonhos que é o meu livro
mais recente né é aproveitando esse
gancho de de falar das coisas que eu fiz
de como cheguei até aqui eu acho que é
importante a gente refletir sobre é esse
mito que se cria do nascer sabendo né às
vezes a gente vê um artista ou 11 um
grande profissional de qualquer área e
tem a impressão de que aquele cara
nasceu
sabe deus foi a epo eliminou o cara do
cara ele nasceu sabendo aquilo
isso não existe na verdade é tudo é um
processo de aprendizado tudo é um
processo que leva tempo que que leva
muita dedicação
daí fundamental para que a gente possa
ter essa dedicação é o envolvimento
emocional que a gente tem com que a
gente faz né
não dá pra gente fazer uma coisa
pensando em objetivos terceiros que não
o prazer de fazer aquela coisa por si
só acho que isso é que motiva a gente a
ficar o dia todo em cima do que a gente
quer fazer e os dias passarem rápidos e
virarem semanas e virarem meses e daqui
a pouco a gente está aqui com um com 10
discos com três livros e com coisas que
de certa forma é totó com e passou para
as pessoas então esse mito que que acho
que acontece um pouco na gurizada que
está na faculdade que está escolhendo a
sua profissão de que as pessoas não
sabem fazer as coisas que então não sei
nada né
eu sempre brinco que pouco o sujeito é
que quer ser músico então ele vai
aprender a tocar violão
ele pega o violão tem que aprender a
final vilão o cara fica afinando violão
passar um mês não desiste e continua
tentando afinal não passa dois meses não
desiste e continua perdendo a final
violão possa três meses não desiste
passa 6 não desistir passa nove existe
porque não dá para violão mas a gente
tem que ter persistência né as pessoas
visitem muito rápido das coisas e aí
acabam não chegando a lugar nenhum e não
fazendo nada ficando um pouco perdido
nesse universo da dadá coisa de enfim
todo mundo focado na internet calaça no
bbb e não constrói uma coisa efetiva
então acho que leva tempo tem que se
dedicar e vale a pena é mais do que nada
vale a pena então assim o envolvimento
emocional a gente se apaixonar pelo que
a gente faz é fundamental como é que eu
sei que eu sou apaixonado claro eu quero
diz pública mas é fácil tudo decidi
trazer música né
e eu não sei o que eu quero fazer eu não
gosto de música não gosta de matemática
não pode nada aí a questão é a seguinte
o que faz uma pessoa se jogar numa
empreitada né meu ponto de vista são
duas coisas o meu desconforto né meu pai
morreu quando eu tinha oito anos de
idade e minha mãe era professora tinha
dois irmãos homens
eu falei cara eu vou ter que nadar
porque a água está batendo na bunda
eu falei vou ter que fazer alguma coisa
aí achei lindo aqui de tocar violão a
estudava 12 horas 14 horas por dia de
violão pelo desconforto porque a água
bater na bunda
né então assim isso é uma forma mais a
forma mais legal é a fascinação e não só
o desconforto é a gente realmente ficar
fascinado com alguma coisa e aquilo nos
seduzir a ponto da gente se jogar aquilo
as mesmas 12 as mesmas 14 horas por dia
eu só tenho 20 minutos como todos aqui e
vim para falar e para tocar então vamos
fazer um pouco de música
vou mostrar um pouco da minha música é
falando de motivação e de zona de
conforto e de desconforto de vacinação
esse novo projeto que é o voto na
bancada é um lance muito louco que eu
tocando esse bumbum aqui que disparam
baixo obrigado eu toco violão uma
técnica de maluco aqui um estudo técnico
pepe com uma batucada na caixa de violão
e que eu tô adorando fazer justamente
porque tá me tirando da minha zona de
conforto e jogando num novo desafio né
então vou mostrar pra vocês um pouco do
voz é uma batucada tocando uma música
chama à espera que beleza
como vai tudo bem
eu vou ser você a frieira a molhar a se
pegue no mar
sei que o sol já se pouco pra nós dois
sei lá uma pedra chão
passarinho na mão
deixa está se a
o feder cada um em seu sol tem seu ice
perde também
tem bom
o tenho
e não sabe que o futuro que viu
a empresa já tapa de passar
você vai você vem
eu não sei por que a frieza molhar
as pegas
sei que o sol já se pôs pra nós do
celular
uma pedra no chão
o pássaro
deixa está se ganha
cada um tem seu som
venceu a cidade também é bom
de não sabe que t
o futuro de vê lo
presente acaba de passar
valeu obrigado
nesse projeto temos afinações diferentes
nessa afirmação não é a formação
tradicional e violão é porque eu levei
seis meses a aprender afinada eu tinha
que trocar as afinações depois então
essa afirmação já uma outra que eu
troquei agora é eu comecei um cara
chamado uma handbike trocar que ele
fazia
me fascinei com essa coisa de poder
fazer a percussão junto com as com
harmonia e tudo ao mesmo tempo aí falei
cara está me motivando para fazer uma
coisa maluca e peguei esse bumbum e
goleiro que já vinha tocando no projeto
do pouca vogal e adaptamos um trigger
que tocam baixo junto e comecei a criar
essas músicas no processo de criação
também já diferente um processo de
criação porque isso é uma coisa bacana
também de falar do processo de criação é
eu lembro que quando eu gravei o segundo
disco a gente foi o estados unidos para
hollywood foi contratado pela polygram
na época para fazer o disco nos estados
unidos eu pensei agora eu vou entender
como qual é o segredo dos americanos
para conseguir aquelas gravações
maravilhosa que na época no início dos
anos 90 nas gravações eram muito ruins
tecnicamente e eles tinham aquele som
gigante assim olha agora vou entender o
segredo que eles têm na qual o segredo
ele tem de ter um aparelho lá que faz
ficar bom né
e aí quando eu cheguei lá em los angeles
naquele segundo disseram que eu descobri
que não tinha segredo nenhum é que a
gente é relaxado mesmo é que os caras
fazem sempre a etapa eles fazem as
coisas corretamente o instrumento qual é
melhor cordas violão há aquela coisa
então bota melhor corda
qual é o melhor cabo abatida tá certa
não tá então treinar batida né
a gente sai agravando assim as coisas e
tentar ajeitar na mixagem e mexia tanto
que ficava ruim né
eles já iam gravando desde o início
certo quando chegava na mixagem de som
tava lindo aí tava tudo certo né então
isso é uma coisa também muito bacana que
a gente treina muito suas etapas e que a
gente não pode pular a gente tem que
respeitar as etapas das coisas e fazer
as coisas direito e não nas coxas como a
gente com muitas vezes costuma fazer
aqui mas é mais um som que chama tudo é
longe
opá alguém longe para se aliviar do que
perto é difícil suportar
é difícil de encarar
calçar os sapatos de alguém que se foi e
esperar que tudo fique pra depois pra
pudesse aliviar de perto
tudo é longe
quero descansar das pessoas do relógio
despertar
da torcida para acertar
ah
a procurar alguém que possa te agradar
tudo é longe
o show
um pouco de você
tudo é louco
opá alguém longe praça aliviar do que
perto é difícil suportar é difícil de
encarar
de perto tudo é longe
quero descansar
das pessoas do relógio despertar da
torcida pra acertar
procurar alguém que possa te agradar
tudo
todo dia você em cada lugar
ah
então tá galera valeu para finalizar vai
fazer amanhã colorido por banda é uma
música que o compositor wado sejam quem
que tocando também aqui
olha luz que brilha de manhã
saiba quanto tempo estive aqui esperando
touch fez sorrir a favor seguir
lembre que hoje vai ter por sol
esqueça o que falei sobre os aí corra
muito além da escuridão não desista de
quem desistir do amor que move tudo
o jovem fala cante uma canção
aperte a minha mão
quebro pé descubra o ideal
saiba que é preciso amar você não
esqueça que estarei aqui ó anjo vermelho
pelo esperma
a passar o tempo está no pensado
terminei o meu espaço
a passar não está pensando
olha luz que brilha de mãe saiba quanto
tempos filha esperando pra te ver sorrir
pra poder seguir
lembre que hoje vai propor se esqueça
que falei sobre sai corra muito além da
escuridão
vermelho pelo escândalo a vida
como está
o veleiro pelo escândalo
ae passar e hotel
obrigado